you know walk him to this video I had
some issue with the recording software
this is why I'm down about 20 seconds
we told English opening yeah
g3 is the normal there are also other
moves a3 for instance the g3 is some
probably the main move okay he went for
better before
you are intending to play d4 I don't
tell to know the exact theoretical play
here but six fairly fairly logical yeah
where do I do now
isn't this isn't this even a known
position okay I think you need to go to
h4 here
the night is a bit offside but yeah you
won this very passive I think every
years the the point if I go f3 he goes
g5 i think i can i can take f6 any for
you yeah this looks this looks like the
way to go and now i've got some pressure
on the FR
Wow just a default yeah come on trustee
for this should should be good
this is controlling me five first and
foremost the tech here play d5 this
Knight e5 so it's not not winning but
what is he and what does this move his
next move probably probably this is
savage this is just good
yeah what I'm not quite sure what's but
something went wrong here for black
black resigns
yeah I didn't he didn't find the plane
before I guess yeah I don't see one once
well compass on plus two point five if
he plays let's say nothing for this one
this is an additional problem yeah check
something like this is just winning for
white yeah I don't know
I think after f3 it's it's already
difficult the conference to defend like
that yeah it says that Knight takes a
three is better surprisingly after he
takes this Knight e5 if it wants to go
here yeah okay I understand no Knight e5
there's tea for him okay
so probably it needs needs to go back
and then in this position yeah why does
enjoying a good central control
for example something like that and then
you fall yeah this is a nice four wide
okay but he needs to do this probably or
maybe there's something else before yeah
this is now excellent for white almost
unplayable that went downhill really
quickly yeah he can suck it like a
psychic piece here but check this is
never enough okay thanks for watching